you've seen me take on law school but
it's time to take on dental school
please welcome Dr Daniel to the channel
thanks for having me are you nervous not
at all Well Medical School is about to
beat dental school because we're the
cooler school all the medical students
say the exact same line so okay well
we're about to find out because he just
yelled at me for not flossing sorry
about that by the way huge thanks to
Sofi for sponsoring this video
which is harder dental school or med
school
it's so obvious dental school obviously
one organ versus 78 organs so we have to
learn all the organs and specialize in
this massive most important organ name
10 organs let's not talk about it right
now let's focus on the question that was
asked and that was cool name three
organs in the abdominal cavity we have a
cavity speaking of cavities let's talk
about your cavity
four years of education plus at least
three years of residency four years of
dental school if you want to specialize
you could get into another four years of
residency or three years it depends on
the on the specialty not only are you
reading books and memorizing facts but
you have to be really good with your
hands so the hand skills have to be not
up to here but Superior and if you're a
surgeon
if you're a surgeon then you're a
surgeon but in Family Medicine we rotate
through surgery because we perform minor
surgeries I'm not going to go and start
opening up someone's abdomen but if in
case of an emergency and I'm your only
hope I can do it or then this could do
it
where did you go to school and for how
long
I went to NYU College of Dentistry okay
and I did my residency oh we're putting
residencies on here too but I did my
degree technicality program at NYIT
College of Osteopathic Medicine not
nyt.com
New York Institute of Technology College
of osteopathic medicine so this was an
accelerated program so I had where's
your under undergrad okay so I'll write
that to you I've been a New York guy
most of my life okay so how long is
dental school four years and college and
undergrad undergrad could be four years
I did undergrad in three years no you
did it yes I did stop by I promise you
you also did a seven year thing it was a
make-believe seven-year thing but I
pushed through like Summers I took
classes so I didn't have to like spend
the four four and a half years in
undergrad I knew what I wanted to do so
I kind of like try to steamroll through
because doesn't Brooklyn College have a
seven year track for for medical medical
for medical school not Dental but yeah
seven years is basically you go you do
the three years you continue on as long
as you meet the criteria of the scores
and yearly GPA and all that stuff how
many schools did you apply to and to how
many were you accepted
you apply to only one school one school
and I got into one school I would not
record your confidence I would not
recommend is that because you have a
white coat on that's exactly the reason
my parents I'm very lucky both my
parents a dentist and they both went to
NYU dental and I just saw that as the
school to go to uh they gave my family
an opportunity to become who they are
today and and I was gonna do whatever I
needed to do to get into this program at
school so the majority of you please
apply to to many many schools I didn't
apply to medical school so this is
actually not accurate I applied to that
seven year program which is undergrad
first and then you just happened to
continue into the medical school right
anyway this is one for one but my dad
also went to the same school it just
used to be called New York College of
osteopathic medicine so we are following
in our family's footsteps and we're very
lucky right we're both very lucky yeah
well our parents did it both as
immigrants right that's true our parents
did it as immigrants who spoke different
languages and we were lucky enough to
follow in their footsteps what was the
best part of medical or dental school
foreign
why because I went into this field to
help people in dental school to be able
to work on you know patients prior to
becoming a doctor I thought it was such
an amazing thing and you know you start
your hand your patients skills in dental
school and who who teaches you is there
like a senior dentist that walks around
and watches you and holds your hand like
yeah so you you do have senior dentists
you have older classmates and you also
have doctors that have retired that are
there uh supervising I've actually been
curious about that do you practice on a
mold first yes so we practice on
mannequins that don't talk don't respond
really that's a real like it took
everything in the materials the same uh
no no it's like plastic teeth oh but is
it a realistic teaching experience not
at all because human beings talk back to
you human beings they moved
everything's moving this mannequin is
the perfect patient yeah the mouth is
open and you could open the instructions
sometimes
I guess sometimes people could even take
out the teeth out of the mouth and drill
it yeah put it back oh they did that
some dental students I know you guys are
watching so wow little cheaters I see
you wow okay so for us it was different
because we had standardized patients so
what does that mean standardized
patients they are paid actors to act
with certain conditions that's cool and
you would literally walk into a room and
you would not know what's going on and
you have to treat it like a real patient
encounter and you have it's time you
have like 15 minutes or whatever the
time was to find out what's going on
with them they're all trained to give
you some scenario with practice
rehearsed answers questions but then
also they have something unique going on
they're really mad they're crying
they're throwing up they would literally
have stuff in their mouth and spit it
out and then you'd get graded on the
encounter from the video of the session
and your note how well it was written
but cadaver lab was the course
for me cadaver lab was the coolest part
because you get to see the parts of the
body that you only see in textbooks in
drawings yeah and it looks completely
different you realize what a mishmash
the body is inside and how everything's
actually interconnected with fascia and
how you need to separate it out and you
you grow a respect for the body but at
the same time when you're studying for
the test and it's midnight and no one
else is there and it's dark it's kind of
spooky that is very smooth yeah it's my
life goal I haven't yet committed to
this because I have some weird fears but
I want to donate my buddy so cadaver lab
wow so if you're a school and you're
interested in my cadaver lab drop a
comment you know what I'll take it one
step further I'll donate my teeth as
specifically as you can recall how much
did it cost to go to medical or dental
school
[Music]
how many years four years but I thought
dental school is three years four years
is it ever three years uh maybe back in
the day they used to be like some
accelerated program but yeah
and I was doing some research because I
went to school many years ago 300 000 it
said almost a hundred thousand just
school not a room and board or anything
right now a hundred thousand dollars is
it NYU Medical School free we award full
tuition scholarships to all current
students where was this when I went to
school
just a quick pause before we dive back
into our engaging discussion you know as
someone who's been through med school I
totally understand the weight of student
debt it can be tough to navigate all the
interest rates and payment plans but
there's good news sofa is here to make
things easier for you Sofi is an awesome
all-in-one finance app that can help you
refinance your student loans offering
competitive interest rates and flexible
repayment options this means you could
lower interest rates potentially saving
thousands of dollars or even consolidate
multiple loans to simplify the repayment
process and it's not just me who thinks
Sofi is great over half a million people
have refinanced more than 30 billion
dollars in student debt with their help
you could be next wanna give it a try
just head on over to sofi.com Dr Mike
don't forget to spell out doctor and
take a minute to fill out your info it's
super quick and checking your options
won't impact your credit score with
sofi's help you can take control of your
student debt and focus on what really
matters all right now that we got that
covered let's jump in with Dr Daniel
what is the worst part medical or dental
school
how often did you get a test because I
still remember honestly I felt like the
second welcome to NYU dental school you
have an exam tomorrow like what the heck
I just got in I don't even know where
I'm at so prior to dental school
everything was on on a piece of paper
you'd take the exams on scantrons and so
forth and I think the year that I went
into dental school they're like we're
gonna do it on the computer I'm like
sounds very technical and cool and
whatever I didn't understand it very
well I wasn't very good at computers so
the first question you know I read it
I'm like you know I don't want to answer
this next question I click next I don't
want to answer right now I think I know
the answer I wanted to skim through it
you weren't allowed to go back
so I'm starting off my career in dental
school with like a 50. we would have
three exams per testing segment you
would have the written exam then you
have your own tea which is the Hands-On
exam and then you also have your cadaver
exam so you're alert you're doing three
exams within one day and that's every
two weeks how would you describe your
professors
foreign
[Music]
I really wanted to get to know them
because I knew that they would play a
big role in my life I did the best that
I could I spent extra hours working on
my craft and I think they saw that they
saw how hard I was working and I saw
that they were willing to devote their
energy and time and these teachers
professors don't make any money really
so they're doing it from the bottom of
their heart and I really respected that
I was very surprised I thought at med
school all the professors and people
would be mean but they actually
genuinely would be upset if someone
didn't do well on an exam because they
felt like they failed what's one of your
fondest specific memories of your time
in school
first test and time during what does it
say trauma you definitely have doctors
handwriting trauma in Brooklyn in
Brooklyn are you a student body
president yeah I was very lucky enough
and honored to become the student body
president that was the first time I ever
got involved in any little politics and
let me tell you sucks any type of
politics is terrible I got to work very
closely with the dean of NYU dental and
he really mentored me on how to approach
a room and how to lead and speak to
people and be kind and generous but also
have your point across in the very
specific way and so just because I went
to dental school doesn't mean that you
can't learn anything else while in
dental school what about you the first
test I did really good I got like a 97 I
was like I'm gonna Crush Med schools
well that what a difference next next
and I got like 50. no but but it was it
was a rough start after and then I
remember during even Hurricane Sandy I
was working in one of the uh level one
Trauma Centers in Brooklyn got to see
some wild scenarios got to learn how to
throw in an 18 gauge IV scrub into a lot
of surgery but also at the same time
learned that I didn't want to become a
surgeon because initially I wanted to do
surgery and I scrubbed it I think to 60
surgeries and I was like this ain't for
me I think that's even more important
than School itself yeah figuring out
what you don't want to do or what
doesn't make you happy well that's why
it's important the first two years of
medical school you learn like The
Sciences the basics and then you move in
and actually learn what it's like to be
on the wards how would you describe your
personal life while in medical or dental
school foreign
[Music]
no but I see I disagree with yours let
me see I think mine happens to be sad
but I don't think it needs to be said I
think you can't have a personal life
once I started to understand how to
study and I was very efficient I had a
little bit more time to unwind a place I
played a lot of sports I went to the gym
did have a little bit of a personal life
but the personal life should not take
over your main goal which is graduating
and a lot of students were failing exams
because they would grow up more more
than they should so you have to be
really self-aware priorities are
important no but why was your sad first
I I moved in and I lived on campus
um like near campus and it was fine it
was going well but then I unfortunately
you know I lost my mom so I had to move
back into Staten Island and because of
that I started commuting then I got used
to the idea of commuting so I almost
fully disconnected from my class and
never created friendships wasn't
involved as a student body president in
the government like I completely lost
all the opportunities to get involved
and I would go out I would have a
personal life but not connected to my
school yeah which sucks what's one thing
you would change about medical or dental
school
[Music]
the amount of exams on a weekly basis
was extraordinary it was too many and I
think that kind of takes away from
actually experiencing dental school and
understanding what it's what Dentistry
is about and and really engulfing within
the community because when you're
constantly just studying for these exams
I mean you kind of miss out and also the
tuition that I think tuition is very
very high very very high and what's
happening is many people that are
graduating from dental and medical
school with these high loans that they
they took on they have to do things
maybe that they shouldn't so they jump
on like a chain Dental just to see as
many patients as possible to try to make
their money back so the ethics and
morals kind of like start to wander
shift and wander away they become more
about money what were your examples I'm
always curious about that what's your
name that's a good one that's a good
like are they asking you questions about
like white blood cell function exactly
pharmacology
um any diseases also any diseases or
just Dental diseases it was like
autoimmune disease exactly so in order
for us to understand the head and neck
we have to understand how the body works
because the mouth is connected to the
rest of the body so you would have like
cardiovascular yes really yes as we went
closer to closer to graduation it would
go from really broad to more narrow
narrow narrow narrow narrow narrow and
then teeth teeth is the last thing that
we focus on well I want to keep the
Krebs cycle and add improv there's a
movement to remove the Krebs cycle from
education and instead bring in like a
more humanistic approach and less
scientific approach to medicine and I
think that's a mistake I think you need
to keep the scientific knowledge in but
our communication sucks as doctors yes
so we need to add improv which forces us
to leave the book and think stop
thinking about the future which we all
do Amen in healthcare and think about
the moment even we communicate really
poorly on social media between each
other attacking each other it gets quite
toxic within the medical communities for
no reason a lot of us are on the same
page we're all on the same team yeah
what is one piece of advice you would
give to someone just starting medical or
dental school today
foreign
from achieving the goal of why you
started medical school or dental school
whatever grade you think is the worst
grade in the world learning how to move
on past that and keep moving forward and
doing the best that you can I think
that's the most important do not let one
exam or class
get back up on the horse get back on
that horse and keep going I just said do
it for the right reason make sure you're
doing it for the right I was gonna write
reconsider but I don't want people to
think that I'm discouraging folks from
going into medicine medicine is in a
tricky place yes where doctors are in a
very tumultuous situation where things
are changing rapidly their skills will
be shifting their reimbursements will be
shifting even style of work will be
shifting it's still worth it because the
field is so rewarding and it's so much
fun and it's it's really cool but with
all those challenges you better be doing
it for the right reasons because if you
think you're doing it to get rich or
you're doing it because
to be a doctor or whatever the case is
that's not it that ain't it you ain't
him you ain't him you bring it back to
the beginning which is harder med school
or dental school
what did this guy write school is more
expensive med school is harder what'd
you say I think medical school and
dental school has the same amount of
problems and Trauma mental trauma all
that stuff but if you do for the right
reasons no no I agree I I think that
both are really hard I just think
there's so much more maybe because I
still don't grasp what's being taught in
dental school it's crazy because you
think you see teeth and there's a tongue
is the lips you're like okay that's
dental school the amount of
understanding and the amount of details
that comes into understand understanding
the head and neck is tremendous okay so
I'll say dental school is more expensive
and Med is harder but only by tiny tiny
bit
pretty tough
but I also took on law school with the
man himself legal eagle click here to
check that out and as always stay happy
and healthy huge thanks to Sofi for
sponsoring this video
[Music]